jean paul belmondo bonsoir je disais on
vous voit dans ce film peut-être qu'on a
l'habitude de vous retrouver est-ce que
cela vous agace un petit peu maintenant
que vous êtes quelqu'un un homme de
théâtre je dirais non non non pas du
tout j'aime beaucoup ce film que j'ai
fait une solitaire qui représente une
partie que j'aime aussi c'est à dire
l'action et en même temps de l'humour et
en même temps je vais la comédie parce
que je crois que des confirmés coup de
poing les gens ont tendance à dire aïe
joue plus la comédie mais c'est pas tout
le film a donné les coups de poing il ya
des moments où on joue la comédie
vraiment il faut dire pour que ce film
est basé sur le plus vieux ressorts du
monde c'est à dire la vengeance vous
êtes à l'afrique
on a tué votre ami vous prenez son
enfant vous le protéger vous allez
désirer que vous vous rendez vous mangez
voilà c'est ça ça pourrait être aussi le
com de monte cristo je crois que c'est
vrai il ya des thèmes au cinéma qui qui
qui existeront toujours et que les gens
aiment toujours et que moi j'aime aussi
toujours il ya la vengeance est un très
beau thème qu'on peut mettre dans
différentes positions entre l'expérience
théâtre que vous vivez actuellement l
expérience cinéma donc notamment avec le
solitaire vous auriez maintenant plutôt
un choix non je crois vous savez je
pourrais avoir un regret et pour être
tout à fait honnête c'est d'être resté
aussi longtemps sans connaître ses
grandes joies que dans le théâtre parce
que là je connais vraiment un bonheur
immense
j'ai attendu un petit peu long terme
maintenant je pourrai plus attendre 27
ans et ça deviendrait dangereux
donc j'en jurerais lotir parlant je
crois que l'idéal c'est de ces de faire
les deux que je vais essayer de faire
maintenant quatre heures tous les soirs
vous êtes autres fatigué non mais c'est
à dire vous savez il faut vivre un peu
comme un sportif c'est comme si je
faisais un championnat tous les soirs
donc j'ai une vie assez monacale et qui
comporte une sieste aussi l'après midi
pour pouvoir péter le feu sur scène le
soir
mais vous savez la fatigue elle s'en va
au baisser du rideau quand on a les
applaudissements du public et qu'on les
sent heureux ça vous enlève toute la
fatigue
merci jean paul belmondo d'avoir répondu
à quelques questions qui fut minutes
avant votre entrée en scène sur théâtre
marigny pour keane et puis on retrouve
donc à partir de mercredi dans le
solitaire de jacques deray